has been burning since Friday sparked by
the derailment of a train two days later
and firefighters are still trying to put
it out
the train was carrying hazardous
materials across northeastern Ohio
concerns that smoke blowing over the
nearby Village of East Palestine may
contain toxins prompted an evacuation
order for tank cars carrying Vinyl
chloride were involved in the derailment
and have been exposed to fire at least
one Vinyl chloride car is intermittently
releasing the contents of the car
through a pressure relief device
as designed
the Thick Smoke could be seen on this
weather radar firefighters were also
forced to leave the area it's still a
very volatile situation some of the cars
were carrying Vinyl chloride a highly
flammable gas its exposure is associated
with increased risk of brain liver and
lung cancer
it's not clear whether those cars are in
flames
so far no trace of the chemicals in the
fumes we have zero readings of any
health risks as far as anything Airborne
coming from the chemicals that they're
looking for
the cause of the crash is still unknown
and the fire could take a few more days
to put out for Abdul Hamid al-jazeera